[Applaudissements]
c'est toujours un peu difficile de
définir ce que ça signifie grandir ou
être grand mois à l'âge de 16 ans j'ai
reçu ma première demande en mariage
ça peut paraître étrange pour vous mais
ça n'était pas du tout pour moi parce
que toute ma vie j'ai baigné dans de
culture la culture sri lankaise celle de
mes origines et ma culture française
celle du pays dans lequel j'ai grandi
aujourd'hui j'ai 24 ans et ce que j'ai
appris de ces deux cultures
c'est que la différence n'est qu'une
question de point de vue
la culture sri lankaise est bizarre pour
un français mais ma culture française et
super bizarre pour un sri lankais points
mais en vrai on est toujours les
bizarres de quelqu'un d'autre
le truc c'est que pour accepter l'autre
il ya un point dispensable faut d'abord
s'accepter soi comme on est peu importe
que les gens voient ou pensent de nous
et plus on grandit plus on s'aperçoit
qu'il est difficile pour moi
voilà comment ça s'est passé ma mère est
née en inde dans une famille très pauvre
et à l'âge de 8 ans elle tombe gravement
malade par hasard un médecin français
l'a recueillie pour la soigner et ses
médecins français blancs c'est mon grand
père il a donc décidé
il a donc décidé de l'adopter mon père
lui est né au sri lanka en pleine guerre
civile
cette guerre qui a duré 25 ans et qui a
fait plus de 70000 mort à l'âge de 16
ans ses parents se sont battus pour
qu'il fuit le pays avec 17 autres
garçons et malheureusement ils ne seront
que très peu à survivre à ce voyage vers
la france et mon père fait partie de
ceux là et moi là dedans
moi je suis né ici j'ai été j'ai grandi
près de paris et j'ai donc grandi aux
côtés de france est donc en clair comme
vous je regarde the voice ou j'écoute
angèle où j'ai un iphone mais pourtant à
bien des niveaux je me sens très sri
lankaise le sri lanka est un pays
absolument extraordinaire
c'est un pays c'est un pays beau coloré
puissant il est peut-être très pauvres
mais sa principale richesse et son
peuple un peuple fier généreuse
solidaire c'est qu'on se contenter de
peu pour être heureux et avec des
valeurs tellement forte
au sri lanka le rapport à l'autre est
différent c'est toujours l'autre avant
soit c'est toujours le collectif avant
l'individu le rapport à la pêche à la
possession est tout autre au sri lanka
on n'est pas heureux parce qu'on possède
on est heureux parce qu'on partage et
toutes les familles du sri lanka vivent
dans des communautés hyper solidaire les
gens sont prêts à tout donner à tout
sacrifier pour venir en aide à quelqu'un
dans le besoin
et enfin tout dans ma culture invite à
la convivialité au partage au fait il ya
des fêtes pour tout tout le temps vous
voulez un exemple concret parler des
règles des menstruations sait comment
pour vous vous êtes à l'aise avec ce
sujet vous pouvez en parler le soir à
table avec vos frères et vos soeurs moi
le soir même où les élus pour la
première fois toute ma famille a
débarqué et on a célébré cet événement
il ya même une grande fête organisée
pour l'occasion ses valeurs cette gaieté
de vivre ont bercé mon enfance et mon
adolescence
elles ont fait de moi ce que je suis
j'ai toujours été très consciente de ses
valeurs et incroyablement fier de les
porter et en fin de compte j'étais la
plus riche en gaz de toute ma famille à
ce stade là de ma vie j'ai à peu près 18
ans et puis je décide de partir faire
mes études à paris partir de loin de ma
famille ça a été un choix déterminant et
pourtant ça ne coulait pas de source
je partais habitait seul dans un
appartement microscopique en plein coeur
de paris
et rien que ça c'était incroyable que
mes parents acceptent parce que j'étais
la première si de toute ma famille a osé
partir seul aucune de mes deux mais tant
de mes grandes quand vous l'avez fait à
dans mon monde partir seul faire ses
études
c'est comme si dans le vôtre vous par en
accepter que vous partiez à l'autre bout
d'amazonie
seul donc en fin de compte pour départ
entre langue à mes parents étaient super
ouvert et ils m'ont vraiment fait
confiance
pourtant tout le monde n'était pas si
ouvert je me souviens que lors d'une
fête qui précédait mon départ
mon père dit à un ami tashi est trop
intelligente
ça va être compliqué qu'est ce que cette
rave sauvage elle peut bien dire ta
fille est trop intelligente ça va être
compliqué
elle m'a longtemps perturbé et je les
garder dans un coin de ma tête je suis
pourtant en partie sans m'en soucier et
j'ai continué de grandir de mon côté
bande miens hélas le décalage a commencé
à faire sentir
vous qui êtes au collège pour la plupart
vous devez comprendre ce sentiment
jusqu'à il n'y a pas si longtemps
peut-être que vos parents étaient des
espèces de super héros invincibles
immortels qui avaient un peu la réponse
à toutes vos problèmes et puis
maintenant vous prenez peut-être
conscience que finalement ils ne sont
pas si parfait ou qu'ils vieillissent un
peu ce sont des êtres humains comme tout
le monde
ben voilà un peu de la même façon j'ai
comme un voile qui s'est levé et qui m'a
fait voir non pas mes parents
différemment mais les codes de ma
culture différemment et j'ai commencé à
entrevoir des choses qui me dérangent
est là où avant je voyais des fêtes
merveilleuse auquel j'avais la chance de
me rendre maintenant je prends
conscience que chaque fête à laquelle je
me suis rendu depuis mon enfance avait
un autre objectif caché celui de nous
observer nous les jeunes filles et de
voir si nous ferions de bonnes mères ou
de bonnes épouses dont la mission serait
de cuisiner poudre tenir la maison ou
s'occuper des garçons
nous n'étions pas là pour avoir un avis
nous n'étions pas là pour faire des
choix et nous n'étions pas complètement
libre alors gelé comprise la phrase du
vieux monsieur tapie est trop
intelligent que ça va être compliqué je
ne rentrais pas dans les cases et
j'étais différente et pas dans le bon
sens alors ça dérangeait dans notre vie
on doit faire des choix pardon dans
notre vie on doit faire des choix et
plus ou moins compliquées ou plus ou
moins difficiles mais qui vont
conditionner qui on est et qui on va
devenir pour moi c'est ça a été le
suivant
est-ce que je dois ou est-ce que je peux
casser les codes de ma culture ou bien
rester dans les traditions pour ne pas
choquer ou décevoir il doit pas être
pleinement qui j'ai envie d'être mon
premier pas
la première fois où j'ai eu l'audace
d'être moi c'était il ya quelques mois
comme je voulais montrer je suis avec un
garçon depuis trois ans
quelqu'un que j'aime passionnément et
sauf que voilà il n'est pas sri lankais
annoncé à mes parents que je suis avec
quelqu'un qui n'est pas sri lankais
c'est comme si vous vous associez à vos
parents ou à vos proches que vous étiez
fait des tatouages et en plus des pires
signer en plus que vous étiez avec
quelqu'un qui est en prison
donc c'était inimaginable de vertige je
n'avais pas le courage et la peur de les
décevoir me ronger de l'intérieur
mais finalement j'ai réussi à le redire
imaginez la scène papa maman j'ai
quelque chose à vous dire j'ai rencontré
quelqu'un et il est français
la scène qui a suivi est la suivante
pendant des heures mes parents ont
verbalisé leurs peurs leurs doutes leur
tristesse leur colère leur déception et
même leur sentiment de trahison parce
que voilà j'aime un garçon qui n'est pas
qui n'est pas ce qui n'est pas être
lankais mais je ne peux pas leur en
vouloir
mes parents sont des gens biens aimant
et généreux et d'une certaine façon ce
n'est pas de leur faute
ma culture pose des cadres comme nous on
nous apprend à dire bonjour madame merci
monsieur dans ma culture nous apprend à
se marier avec des gens de note qu'une
d'autres communautés
c'est comme ça dans ma culture pour ma
part je n'ai jamais été aussi sûr d'une
décision jeu j'avais enfin le courage
d'être moi est d'être honnête avec ce
que j'aime et d'être honnête avec moi
même je pense que ça n'existe pas
vraiment d'être grand je pense que l'on
devient un peu plus grand ou un peu
moins petit à chaque fois que l'on
s'affirme oui bien sûr la vie de nos
proches amis ou famille compte beaucoup
il faut en tenir compte
parce que la plupart du temps ils
veulent notre bien et par exemple si
votre entourage vous dit de ne pas
passer trop de temps sur un écran ou de
ne pas fumer ils ont complètement raison
mais parfois dans d'autres cas ils nous
empêchent d'être libres et ils nous
empêchent d'être nous mêmes j'ai 24 ans
et je pense que je vais continuer à
grandir parce que je commence à
comprendre ce dont j'ai envie et besoin
pour moi
j'ai osé être moi même j'ai osé croire
que mes parents finiront par accepter
mes choix
bon c'est pas complètement gagné mais en
attendant je me sens libéré d'un poids
énorme
on est tous tiraillé par des modes
d'éducation des attentes de nos familles
ou des codes de la société et vous allez
être influencé par ce que font vos amis
ce que vaut votre famille ou ce qu'il
convient de dire ou de montrer sur
instagram
mais posez vous la question est ce que
vous êtes vraiment vous même est ce que
c'est vraiment ce que vous voulez pour
vous et al'inverse est ce que vous serez
être tolérant et accepter que les autres
vos amis ou vos proches aux êtres
différents fasse des choix différents
la richesse est dans la différence
apprenons à l'accepter et je pense que
dans la vie on ne peut être heureux que
si l'on est soi-même
alors soyons moi soyons nous mêmes
merci
[Applaudissements]